et
adopter un chat un chien et vous
comprendrez ce problème sapristi
nouvelle histoire comment allez-vous
j'espère que tout le monde va
extrêmement bien aujourd'hui je vous
racontais l'histoire d'un scientifique
qui avril évidemment sinon je raconterai
pas mais à son histoire était ou est
elle est très touchante ce scientifique
s'appelle john lilly et il a fait un
truc mondialement connu que je pense
énormément de gens par bic vous
connaissent mais après avoir fait ce
truc il est un peu parti en vrille dans
ses expériences et un peu le cliché du
savant fou qui donne tout pour la
science est carrément qui devient caen
perd la tête bref commençons vous allez
voir c'est chelou c'est intéressant vous
allez passer parfum de l'émotion juste
avant que vous raconte l'histoire de
john je vous laisse découvrir l'histoire
d'arthur h tagab
bonjour la gueule tu sais que ton père
est un voleur il a volé les étoiles pour
les mettre dans tes yeux mais comment tu
parles de mon père ou la cette rencontre
fortuite tourner au vinaigre
mon père est effectivement un voleur il
est actuellement en prison aïe aïe aïe
je recommence voulez-vous m'épouser mais
enfin tu met la charrue avant les boeufs
espèce de taré atroce je cherche
personnellement un plan d'un soin si
seulement tu utilisais froot ça nous
aurait épargné cette lamentable
rencontre route comme un fruit non comme
un féculent or évidemment comme un fruit
à c'est une application de rencontres
qui me permet d'éviter les relous dans
ton genre je le prends personnellement
froots me permet de dialoguer avec des
gens qui ont les mêmes intentions que
moi avant même de débuter la
conversation mais comment savoir une
chose pareille sans être messmer le
célèbre télépathe pour commencer tu
choisis un fruit qui correspond à tes
envies la cerise c'est pour trouver sa
moitié quelqu'un de sérieux le raisin
c'est pour simplement prendre un verre
de vin je préfère le rhum seven up
grenadine arrête de me couper ou juste
en colline bien sûr c'est logique la
pastèque c'est pour trouver quelqu'un
qui veut faire des câlins régulièrement
sans pépin et la pêche c'est pour pécho
ce soir yat-il le fenouil c'est mon plat
préféré le fenouil est un légume
je vais maintenant sortir une lacrymo et
en asperger plein le visage je comprends
tout à fait john lilly est américain est
né le 6 janvier 1915 dans le minnesota
dès sa plus tendre enfance il est
passionné par les sciences à tel point
que à 13 ans et construit un laboratoire
dans le sous-sol de chez ses parents
aient réussi à se procurer des produits
chimiques parce qu'il est devenu pote
avec un pharmacien
rien que ça déjà vous avez compris quel
genre d'enfant et d'humains ça va être
il fait donc des études en rapport avec
sa passion il rejoint l'institut de
technologie de californie et là-bas
pendant des années il a étudié la
biologie bref tout roule ibos bien à
l'école il kiffe tout va pour le mieux
en 1934 john découvre un livre qui va
marquer sa vie le meilleur des mondes
d'aldous huxley en gros sa part du
dystopie où les naissances sont
contrôlées par des cocktails chimiques
et aux le gouvernement grâce à une
drogue a rendu tout le monde heureux
alors le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que c'est pas très joyeux voire même
c'est carrément glauque mais john lui ça
le passionne et du coup il se pose la
question suivante comment on fait dans
la vraie vie pour contrôler l'esprit des
gens ça le passionne tellement qui se
spécialise en neurophysiologie
c'est-à-dire l'étude des fonctions du
système nerveux et va bosser jour et
nuit pour répondre à ces questions et va
faire une découverte majeure celle du
burn out more heroes gros craquage il en
a ras le cul à tel point qu'il abandonne
tout et qui devient bûcheron c'est pas
une blague parce que nous on a dit ça
plein de fois sur le pour la blague lui
il l'a vraiment fait et il est victime
d'un accident de bûcheron c'est à dire
que il s'est planté par accident une
hache dans pif il était meilleur en
sciences il se retrouve donc en
convalescence dans un centre de
traumatologie et là il est fasciné par
ce qui l'entourent il veut être médecin
homme bon et ça ça nous fait un point
commun avec lui ce truc d'être incertain
sur son avenir professionnel on le
comprend tous ici et s'inscrit donc dans
une école de médecine la dark mouse
medical school 1938 john est donc en
train de poursuivre ses études il a
continué dans cette voie là maintenant
il passe son temps à disséquer le corps
humain pour en comprendre l'anatomie et
la via un grand jour pour un futur
scientifique celui de sa première
expérience il est son propre cobaye et
son objectif est simple ne plus
consommer la moindre protéines pour voir
l'effet des autres molécules sur le
corps humain alors évidemment ça le rend
extrêmement faible en plus de provoquer
des pensées complètement délirante chez
lui mais ça lui permet publié ses
premiers papiers scientifiques et de
gagner en crédibilité cette expérience
va aussi marquer une grande prise de
conscience de la part de john qui est la
suivante mais je kiffe est le cobaye de
mes expériences surtout qu'on savait ma
santé en danger bref john devient
officiellement chercheur diplômé en 1942
félicitations c'est quand même pas rien
mais c'est quoi la suite fasciné par la
conscience et le cerveau humain john se
met donc à réfléchir à pas mal de
questions comme par exemple pourquoi
quand je lance une gamme de lol mais
alliés sont à chier non ça c'est une
question que je me pose moins lui il
n'ya pas league of legend à l'époque
dont jones pose une autre question
qu'est ce qui se passe si on prive un
être humain de ses cinq sens et cette
question va l'obsédé à tel point qu'il
va développer une toute nouvelle
technologie dont vous avez sûrement
entendu parler qui existent aujourd'hui
qui est utilisé les caissons d'isolation
sensorielle le but est simple si vous
faire flotter dans de l'eau salée coupés
du monde extérieur pour vous éliminer le
plus de vos sens possible alors même si
pour les claustrophobes c'est l'enfer
c'est un truc est censé être plutôt
relaxant et c'est même conseillé aux
gens qui sont très stressés et c'est que
c'est une expérience pas mal après une
petite faute au delà comment ça
ressemble à l'époque c'est d'horreur
bref les caissons fonctionne et
fonctionne un peu trop pour john key à
tendance la nuit à aller dans son
laboratoire pour dormir dans le caisson
il reste parfois dans deezer ici sens
vraiment bien et surtout du coup il a
plein de pensées délirante parce
qu'encore une fois n'est pas fait pour
passer des nuits là dedans malgré tout
il ya plein de scientifiques qui
s'intéressent à cette nouvelle
technologie et qu'ils utilisent pour
leurs propres recherches donc john
devient rapidement un scientifique
renommé est reconnu par ses pairs ce qui
va l'aider à mener la suite de ces
expériences qui sont beaucoup plus
étranges après un an de tripes dans son
caisson john cherche des réponses à de
nouvelles questions et cette fois
nouvelle obsession les dauphins ça a
sûrement un lien avec le fait qu'il ait
flotter dans l'eau pendant un an john
achète plusieurs dauphins qui fait
ramener dans son laboratoire et il
apprend à les connaître on les dit c'est
quand voilà il est 17 pour observer leur
cerveau bassin scientifique et la
découverte majeure leur cerveau est
grand ça veut dire qu'ils sont très
intelligents ces animaux alors depuis on
sait que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça mais à l'époque pour lui ça
semble évident il va les étudier pendant
plusieurs années sont les buts et vivent
cette fois et il va en apprendre
énormément sur leur comportement leur
anatomie à tel point qu'aujourd'hui si
on en sait autant sur les dauphins c'est
en partie grâce à lui en parallèle et
continue ses tripes de 10 heures dans
ces questions d'isolation et un jour
lors d'un triplé pas se poser une
question incroyable il va se dire
nouvelle obsession il va être dans l'eau
salée comme ça dans le noir il va se
dire et si on apprenait aux dauphins à
parler anglais
ils ont un gros cerveau ça va marcher
alors ça sort pas de nulle part c'est
juste qu'au fil des années john a
remarqué que les dauphins sont plus ou
moins capable de reproduire des sons
lorsque des humains parlent à côté d'eux
donc un jour il se débattait qui peuvent
imiter notre langage carrément et parler
comme ça avec nous son obsession
s'intensifient à tel point qu'en
seulement un week end et 300 prises
d'amphétamines il va écrire un bouquin
man of dolphin selon vous est ce que le
livre marche ou pas vous êtes mauvaise
langue c'est un banger absolue le livre
se vend de fouilles a pas de blague il
arrive à convaincre le grand public que
les dauphins veulent parler avec nous
mais pas que le grand public est aussi
plein de scientifiques qui s'intéressent
maintenant à ce délire et aussi la nasa
la nasa elle se dit si on arrive un jour
à communiquer avec des dauphins on sera
sûrement en bonne voie pour un jour
communiquer avec des aliens et en vrai
les dauphins c'est des aliens tout un
regard d'un tribunal en 1963 john
commence donc à recevoir de l'argent de
la nasa pour financer ses études sur les
dauphins pour la nasa le but de l'étude
c'est pas temps d'apprendre à leur
parler c'est surtout de comprendre
comment eux ils communiquent mais john
il a pris trop dans fait il a passé trop
de temps dans son caisson d'isolation il
est convaincu qu'il peut leur apprendre
à parler anglais et aussi les convaincus
qu'un jour les cétacés siègeront à l'onu
et qui nous aideront à prendre des
décisions mondiales
il est parti loin dans son caisson bref
première étape il fait construire un
laboratoire sur l'île de saint-thomas
haut careï après ça il y fait venir
trois dauphins deux femelles pamela et
6,6 et un mâle peter et comment ces
expériences il leur parle tous les jours
il leur fait écouter la radio etc
rien ne marche voilà les dauphins n'y a
pas un mot d'anglais qui sort qui
comprennent pas pourquoi ils sont là ils
veulent juste manger mais en 1964 il
fait une rencontre déterminante celle de
margaret love hate une jeune femme qui
vit sur l'île margaret depuis toute
petite elle est fascinée par un truc
c'est les contes de fées dans lesquelles
les animaux parlent c'est hyper
spécifique c'est vrai que ça me fait
rire bref elle a entendu parler du labo
est donc l aller toquer à sa porte
directement elle a aucun background
scientifique margaret mais elle fait des
remarques très pertinentes
à tel point qu'elle réussit après ce
jour-là a intégré l'équipe du
laboratoire à partir de là il passe donc
ses journées à parler anglais à des
dauphins en espérant qu'ils arrivent à
reproduire les mots on a des petites
images d'archivés de ça regardez c'est
un plaisir
les jours passent les semaines passent
et le soir en rentrant chez elle d'un
gars et elle se met à avoir dépensé un
peu relou elle se met à culpabiliser
elle trouve ça injuste que ces pauvres
dauphin soit enfermé la nuit seul dans
le laboratoire pour remédier à ça elle
fait donc une proposition à john
transformer le laboratoire en maison à
moitié submergée pour qu'elle puisse
vivre avec l'un des dauphins 24 heures
sur 24
pour elle c'est évident c'est la
meilleure manière de leur apprendre à
parler anglais un peu comme une mère qui
apprendre l anglais avec son fils qui
vit avec elle john est un peu surpris
par la demande de margaret pas du tout
ils acceptent sur le champ
la nasa a financé sa rappelez vous c'est
important et et 1965 tout est prêt c'est
le début de la colocation entre margaret
et un dauphin et ce dauphin c'est le
plus jeune des trois peter chaque jour
margaret donne de leçon à peter pour
l'entraîner à répéter ses phrases par
exemple elle essaie de lui faire
prononcer lots maurer est quand ils la
voient mais fait surprenant peter le
dauphin beaucoup de mal à prononcer
cette phrase en anglais serait dingue
d'après elle peter il a un point faible
c'est la prononciation des m ce qui est
chiant quand on s'appelle margaret mais
quand même elle note un truc intéressant
c'est que peter ils essaient de trouver
des techniques pour mieux prononcer les
aime du coût d'un côté cette approche de
vouloir apprendre une langue humaine à
un animal au lieu d'essayer de
comprendre lui sa manière de communiquer
elle et mes gars bizarre mais ça donne
quand même lui à des découvertes
surprenantes et intéressante boury john
dans cette histoire de lescar dans les
étages au dessus du bureau de mme un
gars est un caisson d'isolation
sensorielle ça y est vous le connaissez
le john il passe la plupart de son temps
dans le caisson à tel point que ça
devient carrément plus l'expérience de
margaret là les dauphins que la sienne
alerte on a un nouveau problème peter
l'adorable jeune dauphin est de plus en
plus perturbé lors de ces leçons
d'anglais mais que se passe-t-il et bien
peter atteint la puberté et du coup il
passe ses journées à penser à une seule
chose qu'elle en
du coup avant chaque cours d'anglais
c'est un collégien peter c'est
incroyable il le déplace avec les deux
autres femelles du laboratoire pour qui
se détendent un peu sauf que c'est une
galère de déplacer un dauphin deux fois
par jour et campus malgré sa peter il
est toujours pas concentrés pour ces
deux sont anglais et il semble de plus
en plus insistant auprès de margaret
genre il aime bien se frotter à elle de
plus en plus souvent
yes
c'est alors que pour le bien de la
science oui messieurs dames il se peut
que margaret
alors blague à part sachez que l ça la
dérange pas plus que ça elle est
vraiment en mode bas je m'en fous si je
derrière il saura
ça valait le coup sauf que malgré cela
la mission avances pas trop quoi dire le
petit peter il vient prendre sa petite
quotidienne et il sort pas de mots en
anglais après la nasa commence à
s'impatienter il n'y a pas de résultats
d'expériences ya pas de retour sur
investissement et donc john doit agir et
vite il a donc une nouvelle fois une
idée hors du commun il se dit et si je
filais du lsd au dauphin t on parle
anglais un niveau élevé de quoi mais là
ça ira depuis tout ce temps les dauphins
tente en fait de communiquer avec lui
par télépathie et ils pensent qu'en leur
donnant du lsd ils y arriveront margaret
troubles idée horrible elle trouve ça
vraiment pas éthique bon alors après il
ya d'autres trucs sont pas éthiques dans
l'histoire rama yade
malgré tout john c le boss il fait ce
qu'il veut donc qui leur donne du lsd et
là il se passe rien mais dauphin il n'a
juste pas spécialement il se passe que
dalle grâce il se passe un truc c'est
que la nasa apprend que john a donné du
lsd au dauphin et elle coupe
définitivement tout financement il y en
a ras le cul je voulais juste comprendre
comment les dauphins communique fallait
leur donner du lsd là c'était précis dur
john le laboratoire ferme donc
définitivement ses portes mais alors que
deviennent margaret et john déjà parlons
de margaret elle a le coeur brisé elle
s'est occupée pendant mes galons temps
de peter elle était en colocation avec
lui elle a développé une relation de fou
avec lui un peu comme un humain avec un
chien et ce dauphin qui était un peu son
animal de compagnie bell ne peut pas le
garder il est donc rapatrié aux états
unis dans un delphinarium et quelques
temps plus tard il décède et on suspecte
qu'il soit en réalité mort de chagrin en
fait les dauphins respire de façon
consciente pas comme nous et donc peter
se serait laissé mourir dans son bassin
sûrement par tristesse de ne plus voir
margaret écemment
l'histoire d'un gars et ne s'arrête pas
là parce que quelques années plus tard
la presse découvre cette affaire est un
énorme magazine pour adultes de l'époque
haussler qui s'empare de la faire et qui
fait un article et une couverture sur ce
sujet ça fait énormément de bruit et en
même temps regarde moi cette couverture
mon pote c'est hard à partir de ce
moment-là margaret se fait donc dix
femmes est partout tout le monde se fout
de sa gueule etc et la crédibilité de
john en tant que scientifique est
définitivement détruite en parlant john
il devient quoi lui écouter et compte
les expériences sur lui-même et son kiff
c'est explorer les limites de son
conscient ça c'est du bullshit en gros
ça veut dire se démolir la gueule
malheureusement coup dur pour john les
états unis classent le lsd comme
produits illicites comme drogue dans les
années 60 et donc john n'a plus d'autre
choix que de se remettre en question ou
de trouver autre chose comme par exemple
la kétamine en vrai c'est triste il se
démolit tellement la gueule qu'un jour
dans son bain il est en train de se
noyer mais il se rend pas compte ce
qu'il est très défoncé et c'est sa femme
par chance qui est venu le voir dans la
salle de bain et qui lui a fait du
bouche-à-bouche il s'est fait héliporter
à l'hôpital et c'est pour lui s'il a
survécu c'est un signe le signe qu'il
existe une entité extraterrestre qui
protège sa vie selon lui il existerait
un bureau de contrôle des coïncidences
sur terre l'écho en anglais heureuse
coïncidence control office dirigé par
des aliens venus d'une autre galaxie
d'être merci ta femme g john au cas où
en tout cas cette découverte ils
l'assument complètement il écrit même
une tonne de livres pour exposer sa
philosophie il apparaît aussi à la télé
pour en parler mais il est allé
tellement loin dans son exploration du
psychisme que plus grand monde n'arrive
vraiment à le comprendre et en plus de
ça malheureusement son délire avec les
aliens va s'intensifier avec le temps un
jour par exemple ils ont la télé avec sa
femme et après s'être injecté une dose
de chez pas quoi ils crient ils hurlent
et il dit à sa femme que l'écho vient de
lui voler son pénis c'est ce qu'on
appelle en bad trip est découverte un
autre jour john et en moto il se crashe
parce qu'il était une nouvelle fois
drogué mais il a de la chance il s'en
sort miraculeusement avec juste des
côtes cassées et une fracture au crâne
pour lui s'il a survécu encore une fois
c'est un signe du bureau des
coïncidences et d'ailleurs à l'hôpital
il a déclaré avoir reçu la visite de
deux aliens du bureau des coïncidences
qui leur est soumis à un dilemme qui est
le suivant soit il continue à fond la
drogue et il part avec eux soit ils se
calment sur sa consommation et ils
restent sur terre quand les aliens
s'inquiète pour ta consommation de
drogue c'est qu'il est vraiment temps
d'arrêter et écouter ça fait plaisir
cette fois c'est pas une blague john se
calme vraiment sur la drogue il arrive à
sortir de son addiction dans les années
80 il tente une nouvelle fois de
communiquer avec les dauphins cette fois
à l'aide d'ordinateurs
mais sa foi en 1990 john prend
définitivement sa retraite il se retire
sur une île hawaïenne où il finira
paisiblement ses jours et ce qui est
beau c'est qu'il laisse déjà une
histoire improbable derrière lui mais
aussi pas mal de succès envoie les
caissons sensorielle c'est une vraie
technologique a impressionné le monde
scientifique est aussi son travail sur
les dauphins qui quand même a permis
d'attirer l'attention du grand public
sur les mammifères marins en plus de ça
john avait des valeurs par exemple il a
toujours refusé de collaborer avec
l'armée qui voulait à l'époque en savoir
plus sur les dauphins pour dans le cadre
de la guerre froide les transformer en
armes de guerre donc oui john était
perché surtout à la fin de sa vie la
drogue n'a pas dû l'aider en plus de ça
mais il aura fait de mal à personne il
aura juste été un peu trop dans son
monde loin du nôtre
c'est la fin de l'histoire de john et de
margaret du coup j'espère que ça vous a
plu vous penserez à moi si jamais vous
allez dans un caisson d'isolation
sensorielle tout son histoire vachement
touchante et surtout comme il était prêt
à être le son propre cobaye pour essayer
de faire des découvertes il était très
curieux il était passionné par le plein
de trucs ce gars il a une grosse
addiction à la drogue évidemment dont là
je pense beaucoup souffert mais c'était
les années 60 70 c'était une autre
époque il a fini accro à l'époque il
prenait des trucs des médicaments qui
aurait été purement des drogues et
pouvait être très dangereux pour
l'humain et tout le monde s'en bat les
couilles c'est vraiment une autre époque
mais je trouve que john il reflète bien
cette époque dans sa carrière voilà je
trouve son histoire assez où j'espère
que ça vous a plu on se retrouve bientôt
dans une nouvelle vidéo je ne sais
toujours pas comment finir les vidéos
après dix ans sur youtube il c'est grave
allez je vous laisse et c'est au fait
j'ai dit au revoir comme quand je pars
d'une soirée
[Musique]